one of the things I think is really
important for all of us to be able to do
is to figure out when we see a headline
when we start seeing something enter the
discussion and get repeated over and
over again and it's a major claim we
need to be able to figure out for
ourselves is it backed by evidence or is
this disinformation or misinformation
and we have the perfect example today
there's a new I'm I'm going to use some
of the words they're using even though
they're BS quite frankly there's a new
quote study
about covet vaccines from quote Florida
floating around
which I started seeing over the weekend
during my live streams I saw some of the
people in the chat saying David new
study from Florida says that covet
vaccines increase heart attacks by 84
percent in the month after one is
vaccinated when you get a vaccine
your odds of a heart attack go up 84
percent for the month after you've
received that vaccine so the first
question with all of these things is
does it pass the sniff test so with some
of these things you know uh it turns out
we don't breathe oxygen we actually
breathe
um really light water you know so I
don't know we would say this doesn't
even pass the sniff test it's not really
even worth looking into now let's
imagine it were true that getting a
coveted vaccine increases your chances
of a heart attack by 84 percent we would
be talking about so many heart attacks
heart attacks and deaths that we would
have heard about this more so more
quickly than two years into vaccination
but let's imagine that we want to take
this seriously and explore it the source
of this is Florida's Surgeon General
Joseph ladapo a known anti-vaccine voice
and ours Technica has a really good
write-up about the so-called analysis
and he put out a statement on Friday
that men age 18 to 39 should not get the
covid vaccine why not well he claims to
have an analysis called exploring the
relation relationship between all cause
and cardiac related mortality following
covid-19 vaccination or infection in
Florida residents a self-controlled case
series study there is then a press
release about the analysis so now we're
like a layer removed now it's a press
release about an analysis the press
release says covet vaccines cause an 84
percent increase in the relative
incidence of cardiac related death among
males 18 to 39 within 28 days following
mRNA vaccination there's a lot of
important data in that claim or
important metrics in that claim which we
are going to look at so let's take a
look at the analysis one of the things
you might notice when you pull up the
analysis is it's supposedly from the
Florida Department of Health but it's
not on Florida Department of Health
letterhead that's sort of weird for an
analysis supposedly from the Florida
Department of Health there's no authors
listed on the study well that's really
weird and of course it's not peer
reviewed
obviously I mean is that there's not
even a claim that it is or that it's in
any journal or that that has been
reviewed in any way so what is the
analysis that has been done well the
first thing is they did what's called a
self-controlled case series
we're going to talk about what that is
how should we look at vaccine safety
you would want to take a group of
vaccinated people and a group of not
vaccinated people maybe they get a
placebo the non-vaccinated people so no
one even knows whether they are or
aren't vaccinated you match them up
demographically so that in both of these
groups you have similar underlying
health statuses other parameters age Etc
and you compare them over a period of
time which of the groups over a period
of time the vaccinated or unvaccinated
group has more infections or more cancer
or more car accidents whatever and the
idea is you want to make vaccination the
only variable one group has the vaccine
the other doesn't and they are otherwise
identical groups in a self-controlled
case series which is what was done
there's no control group the only people
in their study
um are the people that
um are being studied and whose outcomes
are being measured there's no control
group it's uh you know you've got a
covet vaccine died within 25 weeks and
then they look subsequently at the group
that died within the first four weeks
and what they wanted to see was are the
deaths clustered in the first four weeks
after the vaccination which is
considered the risk period for a vaccine
during which a side effect or a
complication could happen and so they
they look at the first four weeks and
then they call weeks 5 to 25 the control
group that doesn't make sense that's not
good science and I'm getting so wound up
that I punched my microphone now what
they also did was they excluded people
from the study
who had coveted died of covid and they
excluded people with boosters
why would you do that wait a second you
want to study something related to covid
and the vaccine you have no control
group and you exclude people from the
study who had kova died of covet or had
a booster meaning they went beyond their
first two-dose regimen well that's
nonsense that doesn't make sense they
also don't actually have any medical
information for cause of death they only
have death certificates and as we know
death certificates through no deliberate
attempt at fraud don't always represent
the heart of the matter for lack of a
better term about how someone died
sometimes you die because of a
complication from covid that
complication goes on the birth
certificate but not the fact that you
had covid and the reason you were in the
hospital was coveted and then a
complication came up just as one example
they don't know how many people died of
undocumented covet cases after one dose
of the vaccine for example where one
dose of the vaccine is not considered
that you are protected
that's not actually a full regimen even
the cardiac related causes of death
might not be the analysis says in it
quote cardiac related deaths were
ascertained if a code of
i3152 was on the death certificate thus
the underlying cause of death may not be
cardiac related they're even saying some
of these cardiac related deaths might
not really be cardiac related they also
didn't separate out people with mRNA
vaccines and non-mrna in a clean-cut way
they claim to be studying the effects of
mRNA vaccines remember the Johnson and
Johnson vaccine is not an mRNA vaccine
they have two classifications they have
people with an mRNA vaccine and people
with a non-mrna or unknown type of
vaccine
you could have
obvious misclassification when those are
your categories and it also only looked
at men 18 to 39. now there's two
important things about that first of all
they combined 18 to 24 and 25 to 39 why
would they do that
when the underlying data separates those
into two groups 18 to 24 25 to 39 why
would you combine them well they don't
say and of course the speculation is
that by combining those two groups you
get them the finding that they wanted
this is a version of What's called the P
hacking Google p hacking and and you'll
very quickly learn what that is last
thing the number of deaths in the
specific group they studied was 20.
during the first four weeks and then 52
in the so-called control period 5 to 25
weeks and the sample sizes are so small
and it's not really a control group that
the data are essentially meaningless so
don't fall for it
Joseph ladapo should be more concerned
with disease outbreak in Florida
following the hurricane and power
outages which is a real issue after a
natural disaster uh than putting
together these bogus so-called analyzes
messing with the data no control group
wrong type of study on and on and on so
when you see the headline now vaccines
cause 84 increase in cardiac death
you now are equipped to understand that
the so-called analysis is completely
bogus
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the U.S alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 made from bamboo a bamboo
stock keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one American uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
Soft toilet paper real paper loves the
David Pacman show they're giving my
audience 30 off your first order and
free shipping when you go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below